the grand dumb is back for round number
five how are you feeling about season
five
i'm super excited you know um it's a
great
season we killed it again
i mean yeah you guys have never not
delivered a season and we had to wait a
little bit longer for this one but i
feel like it's going to be well
worth our weight it is so worth the wait
um i know
you know fans i just love them i want to
thank them for the love and support
because they have a
baby on may 3rd when we push back but
those things that are worth waiting for
i'm just saying they're so good
all right fill in the blank with one
word season five of the real housewives
of potomac is
karen you're going to reclaim that name
and make it a good i already did it well
let's dive right into what we're going
to get this season
the trailer and the premiere episode
kind of sets up that
you and ray are in a place are you in
love with me over time
things change i'm done how would you
describe that place
it's a place of work and a marriage i
think what
ray and i bring this season is just so
important as far as sharing
a truth about a 24 year old institution
called marriage and not without its
moment
and we don't hold back and we
work through is it a turning point or a
breaking point
or something else it propels i'll say
that
it propelled and when you think you
can't go further you figure
you can go a little higher well and you
mentioned right before we sat down that
you had called out to ray
to get the internet working so you
you're still in the same house
things are gonna are you kidding me i
said literally in quarantine i'm sitting
here right with right
yes well because in the trailer there is
kind of a very candid moment
we've been together 25 years
yeah you talk to
me about what takes you to that
confession i think that you have to
witness it all when women get together
such as ourselves the girls have
housewives of potomac you know there's
there's a sisterhood and there's a
healing in
talking things through and so
i can't fill in the blanks you know
bravo is
so wonderful at how they present
everything um and they want me to uh
say stay tuned it's worth live thank you
did you surprise yourself at all with
what you were willing to share and what
you brought to tv
i think no honestly i think more people
are surprised that i'm so down to earth
i'm all that all that you guys have seen
for five years
all of that is me and so this as well is
a part of me
and i don't exclude any part of karen in
order to be on reality tv
and i think that's what the viewers and
my fans relate to they're like oh my
gosh she's so funny
but then when she's hurting she's
hurting when she's loyal she's loyal i'm
all those things so no i
i had no no caution no has hesitant
you know behavior toward just being real
for reality tv
no and did you learn anything about
yourself
or your relationship in kind of having
these open
conversations about the state of what it
was i learned so much about
myself and about right um and it was
important to take
that lesson and and to be a student at
that moment i can thought in
monique quite a bit um our friendship is
just
you know that type of friendship where
you can just open up and be honest about
where you're sitting in your
relationship
and um i'm not surprised um i learned so
much about
myself i i learned what i will do for
family
that that and you don't think you can
keep growing
i kept crawling well i think that's kind
of where you set things up with
okay we're a quarter of a century into
this
thing called marriage oh my god did you
say a quarter of a century whoa yes but
we are
i mean it's just a fact kevin you said
24 years a second ago
it is but i gotta tell i'm gonna use it
i'm ready though go ahead
um but then you're also saying you know
the what is it a 17-year age difference
doesn't feel as
big when you first get into the marriage
but as you grow into it
sometimes that divide becomes bigger and
bigger
i wouldn't call it divide i i would just
call it a disconnect
the disconnect is is frightening and so
you got to stay tuned and see how we
deal with that uh you brought up monique
things go to a place we haven't seen
before on potomac with candace
and monique
what can you tell me about what leads us
to that moment
i can just say this no one could have
told me that moment was going to happen
i watched in awe and i
also want to share that two wrongs don't
make it right
and that's the teaser i'm giving you
guys this season y'all do the math
i've always been a strong advocate for
what's right it's right what's wrong
it's wrong
uh i don't change on this and it's very
um
difficult for me to watch what
transpired
but i'm always hopeful stay tuned
but we also do see in the aftermath of
that it appears almost like the ogs
have a come to jesus meeting with
monique uh
to talk through that we never thought as
black women we would be right here but
we are
it's not something you can brush under
the rug but you've got to address this
we have been able to hold ourselves
above
the stereotype and in five minutes
she took it away what can you tell me
about
what that conversation was like and
kind of the what comes from that
conversation uh
it's important to understand as the og
of rhop
i will facilitate anything that allows
us to
express ourselves in a positive way and
have a discussion that most people would
be uncomfortable about
i can say that it was a very fruitful
moment
and you'll see a lot of growth and a lot
of pain and and love
um yeah
and other things i think
the pain is right there in the teaser i
by
no means wants to be near you
and maybe i don't need to be a part of
this anymore
did she take a step back after that did
you ask monique this
uh i haven't talked to her yet i can
tell you
what i advise my friend to do um to take
care of herself
first and then whatever you call that
that's what she did and she did it
very committed and i respect her for it
what i think is so great about potomac
you guys have never shied away from
having those difficult conversations on
screen and really talking about issues
that matter
uh i mean first season you guys got into
the whole colorism
discussion that happens within the black
community and obviously there is a
big social movement happening and i just
want to get your take on uh
how you think that could impact what
kind of conversations you guys have on
the show in the future obviously this
season was filmed
before we had this kind of reckoning on
racism but
um you know i honestly believe that rhop
will be the place to have a conversation
we started it as you said from season
one we will continue to walk in truth
honesty pain love and hate until black
lives matter
and that i wouldn't i would
doubt it seriously if it did not if it
didn't come up at reunion or
sixth season it's a subject matter that
has to be taught
uh and i'm here to educate so yes
well i think a lot of people learn from
entertainment too because it's one we
didn't learn a lot about this in our
history books
um and two it comes realer
you know when you have somebody who can
share their experience and i just wanted
to know if you
had either your first memory of racism
existing
or a moment of racism you've experienced
that has really stuck with you that you
could share
absolutely absolutely um i was lucky i
was born at the end of the martin
luther king march so i benefited greatly
from
those black leaders in the 50s and 60s
but when i was in blydal arkansas and my
son was about to
i'll never forget um this up this
woman walked in front of me at the
grocery store and
she says uh you need to step back i'm
gonna pay for my goods first and
i was working for poverty law at the
time and so i said
what we're not going to do is we're not
going to do this and i and then the
little girl at the cash register bless
her heart she said
man you're just making it difficult for
us i said sweetheart you need to
understand your civil rights
now i said what we're going to do is
check miss karen out now
and then we're going to let this lady go
nicely second and last and
so it was a moment for me though to
quote my civil rights uh i never have to
and to do it in front of my two-year-old
son what a powerful moment and i'll
never forget it
um but it's important that those who
don't know their rights
be educated at this moment and those who
don't know that
or think that black lives don't matter
it's time to have a conversation and
some education
and we can do 100 your kids are
obviously grown
at this point but what i imagine you're
still having conversations with them
about what's happening can you share
that with me
it's painful for them i've raised my
children in love and hope
um but they were ready because they are
educated
i think education is the key while it
was
painful to have this conversation with
them
it was very needed to refresh their
memory
um and and to let them know i have them
in love
conquers all uh and and that our
foundation as a family will carry
us through whatever challenges we face
through black lives matter
but it does matter so we're even even
marched by the way
uh yeah this record seen herself for
like 14 days but she
she had to get out there there was she
felt the
need to represent her family and i just
love her for that strength and courage
and i just wonder where she gets it from
[Laughter]
i was going to say i think you can pat
yourself on the back that had to have
been a proud mom moment
yeah it certainly was you know i'll be
glad when we do
get through this but i don't want to get
through it in such a rush that we missed
the lesson as we did
previously i don't want to do that so
you're stupid for a moment or teacher
how about a teacher
yeah i think you can speak from the
point of view of a teacher at this point
okay
but thank you let's take it back to the
show okay
what are we gonna see from you and
giselle because you know that you are
one of the most dynamic duos in all of
the housewives canon
it's a winding road it's been good it's
been bad what's it like season five
i think this season you'll see
acceptance expect i can only speak for
me i accept yourself
good bad different shenanigans you know
just depending on which which hat she's
wearing that day
i'm cool with it i can do both i can do
it all with her um
but for me you'll just see acceptance
for everybody
every you know it takes all seven of us
to make this thing called
rhop and and the fans love and support
and so i i'm at a point of acceptance
and you know
you are what you are and i will treat
you accordingly
that says a lot that statement
that does me yeah are there any wig
shifting moments this year
i perfected these wigs have you not
heard ladam is killing it
in the fragrance and hairline i just i
though no weird [ __ ] um
any metaphorical wig shifting moments
things that could have blown your way
back
well probably probably no i i
look this platform has supported me
the opportunity to exercise my
personality which is humorous sassy
classy
bossy but loving okay and so
yeah i got some shifting moments that i
put down for y'all
and i think they'll be i don't ever
intend for them to go down in history
the way they do
but i have a sense of humor and timing
in my personality which i'm very
grateful for and bravo catches us so
you're gonna get some
you mentioned that there are now seven
of you yeah
then champagne flutes in that opening
sequence we got dr
wendy joining the cast for this season
and in the
in the first episode uh you say i'm
aware of dr wendy i know her from this
social circle this bored and
unimpressed i think it's the word you
use yeah
yeah yeah you know wendy and i are open
to growing um
getting to know one another and we do
have a history
um and you'll see that okay
how do you feel about wendy now i'm open
to wendy
i always was even with our history and
and and challenges as women um
it's something about her that is
powerfully
genuine and i like that so i'm gonna
it's a wait and see it's a wait and see
you know i got to see what's
about me from the confessional church
then i'll tell you what i think okay
okay so right now your door is open tbd
if she walks through it or not
yes right tbd well what else can we
expect this season it looks like we're
gonna maybe have a little deja vu moment
with ashley and michael
yeah um you all will i won't
[Laughter]
oh my god he was asking who we can take
to a hotel nearby
but i'm sure they'll work it out and
with them nothing but the best because
they too i think they're five years or
six years
now so that's nothing to you know call
that or just dismiss
so marriage is marriage and let's see
where it goes for them i wish them
i wish them happiness did ashley
becoming a mom
change at all kind of the dynamic with
her
i i think any woman becoming a mother
would change you
and you know we'll see we'll see i'm
always looking at absolutely like
crosstalk like okay where where's the
messy stirred up
um but baby dean gave her a run for
money i can teach you with that
well what are you most excited for fans
to experience in season five
i'm always trying to go deeper the next
season because people are like well
you know they think they know me and
then they're like oh my god i really
don't know her
so i went a little deeper to the
foundation in the root of who i am
uh and shared a family with you
is there anything that you're
scared to watch back or scared for the
audience to experience
never never scared never you can't be
for what it's too
late and another thing you just own who
you are
you know um so no nothing that i'm
afraid of nothing that i can't
handle as a grown woman nothing